Even during this age in which a new great
TV show seems to premiere every couple of
weeks, there are a few clear standouts.
These all deserve to be included in the best
TV seasons of all time.
Breaking Bad is one of those shows that is
about as perfect as television gets.
That said, the further along the show progresses,
the more tense and action-packed it becomes.
Choosing between seasons four and five is
tough, but we have to give the nod to the
absolutely riveting final season of the show.
When season five starts, Walter White has
ascended to the top of the drug trade.
He's eliminated his greatest rival and seemingly
nothing stands in his way.
However, such an astronomical high paves the
way for a devastating fall.
The season pays off everything the story has
been setting up - and throws in a few killer
twists along the way, including the moment
Walt's brother-in-law Hank discovers Walt
is the mysterious meth kingpin that he's been
chasing for years.
["I gotta say, I don't like the way you're
looking at me right now."
It all blows up in the final three episodes,
one of which, "Ozymandias," is a serious contender
for the best episode of television ever made.
There are few TV series more divisive than
Lost.
Still, despite the controversy, the show's
first season is a genuinely special piece
of television.
Right from the pilot, the season hooks you
in with stellar character work and plenty
of engaging mysteries.
It builds its characters with stunning efficiency
and economy, perfectly balancing character
histories with exploration of the island's
mysteries.
Later seasons would skew this balance too
far in either direction, but the show's debut
season gives as much attention to the mystery
of the hatch as it does to Jack's relationship
with his departed father.
From the perfect pilot to the riveting finale,
season one of Lost is just as good today as
it was when it first aired.
"I've looked into the eye of this island,
and what I saw was beautiful."
Parks and Recreation really hit its stride
around its third season, but season four cemented
the show as an all-time great television comedy.
[Laughter]
Even without the season-long throughline of
Leslie's city council campaign, season four
provides several all-time great episodes,
including "Ron and Tammys" and "Pawnee Rangers."
Paul Rudd's Bobby Newport absolutely steals
the entire season as he wanders in and out
of the season with a guilelessness that few
other actors could pull off.
"We're not gonna quit the campaign.
Why would we do that?"
"Because!
I want it.”
It's the most memorable, most quotable season
of an already very memorable and quotable
comedy.
"You get fired, I'll quit and we'll leave
together.
I'm serious.
Move to a new city, change our names, burn
our fingertips off with acid, swap faces."
“What?”
We live in an era in which superhero shows
and movies are a dime a dozen.
The best way for one to stand out is to center
itself around unique themes, and Jessica Jones'
first season does this better than just about
any entry in the genre.
The season serves as a 13-episode meditation
on trauma, abuse, and recovering from toxic
relationships.
It never flinches from the unpleasantries
of such subject matter, and handles it with
the delicate touch necessary.
Past that, it's anchored by a very strong
hero and a very strong villain.
Krysten Ritter shines as Jessica, while David
Tennant turns out a uniquely menacing performance
as the villainous Kilgrave.
Shocking and emotionally resonant, these episodes
will leave audiences reeling for years.
Justified is anchored by the compelling rivalry
between Timothy Olyphant's U.S. Marshal Raylan
Givens and the magnetic criminal Boyd Crowder,
played by Walton Goggins.
"What're you packing?"
"You'll pay to find that out."
"Oooh, you got ice-cold water running through
your veins."
However, as stellar as the interplay between
those two is, it's not the focus of the series'
best season.
That honor goes to the second season's story
revolving around the Bennett family.
The Bennetts run a crime enterprise dealing
in everything from moonshine to marijuana.
Raylan is charged with bringing them down
and as you might expect, things don't go according
to plan.
The way the season establishes the series'
setting of Harlan, Kentucky as the kind of
hometown you can never fully escape makes
for a pitch perfect story and a great piece
of development for Raylan himself.
Of particular note is Margo Martindale doing
what is easily the best work of her career
as Mags, a terrifying rattlesnake of a crime
boss.
"Coover, I know you're sorry.
That's why it's gonna hurt so much to have
to do this."
Bloodline revolves around the Rayburns, a
large family residing in the Florida Keys.
When their oldest son Danny returns from an
extended disappearance, events are set in
motion that lead to Danny's death at the hand
of his brother John.
The show chronicles the march to Danny's murder
nonlinearly.
Rather than obsessing about the plot, most
of Bloodline is carried through conversations,
micro-aggressions, and slowly simmering feuds.
Bloodline's first season is an addictive,
compelling family drama that will leave you
screaming at your TV by the finale's closing
moments.
Season four of New Girl sees the show regain
its footing after an uneven third season and
truly become the best possible version of
itself.
More than any season of New Girl, these episodes
delve into hilariously exploring modern dating,
like when Jess downloads a pseudo-Tinder app
for the first time.
That said, the easy standout is "Background
Check," which ranks among the greatest TV
episodes of all time.
The story sees the gang subject to an in-home
background check as part of Winston's application
to become a police officer.
Over the course of the examination, the crew
spirals into insanity.
"I just need you to pretend like you're in
a relationship with this grown man that I
know - Ah!
I did not think this through.
I did not think this through."
Easily one of the odder sitcoms in recent
memory, New Girl was never more irreverent
or wonderful than it was during its fourth
season.
By the time the sixth season of Game of Thrones
comes around, the story has progressed past
territory covered by the book series it's
drawn from.
This left the showrunners free to run wild
with the story and take it in new, surprising
directions that can't be spoiled by the books.
They build a number of conflicts to a head,
like the war between the Starks and Boltons
for control of the north, and pepper in a
hefty number of game-changing revelations.
From Daenerys finally making her way to Westeros
to the Battle of the Bastards, Game of Thrones'
sixth season is riveting genre television.
In just eight episodes, True Detective's first
season accomplished more in terms of creativity
and critical acclaim than some shows do in
ten-season runs.
The miniseries stars Woody Harrelson and Matthew
McConaughey as surly detectives attempting
to solve a series of murders.
The story is told nonlinearly and features
some seriously dark philosophical tangents,
which creates even more mysteries for the
viewer to solve.
"You get any sleep last night?”
“I don't sleep.
I just dream.”
True Detective wears its influences on its
sleeve from the start.
It's packed with Lovecraftian themes and structure,
making a story about two men hunting a killer
feel otherworldly.
It borrows from plenty of well-loved literature,
but the show doesn't simply rip off these
stories.
Instead, it uses them to create a depth of
influence, to give viewers more to dissect.
"I contemplate the moment in the garden, the
idea of allowing your own crucifixion."
When this is combined with the dense themes,
fully formed characters, and complex plot,
the result is a show you can analyze and break
down a million different ways.
It's massively compelling television, the
likes of which we haven't seen since.
Much of the first season of A.I. sci-fi drama
Westworld centers on the idea of a maze.
The show's characters, both human and robot,
find themselves drawn into a conspiracy involving
a maze symbol left by one of Westworld's original
founders.
While it's easy to get distracted by the stellar
performances and special effects, the mystery
is what makes the show so memorable and addictive.
"I think there's a deeper meaning hiding under
all that.
Something the person who created it wanted
to express."
Modern TV shows love mysteries, but few shows
manage to pay them off in ways that don't
cheat the viewer in some way.
Westworld is the rare mystery that never makes
this mistake.
Its plot is structured like the maze it revolves
around.
By the time we reach the center of the maze,
it's just as shocking to us as it is to them.
It's an amazing start to an amazing series.
Few shows have changed the game like The Sopranos.
The modern concept of prestige television
can be traced back to the runaway success
of HBO's mob drama.
The whole run is excellent, right up to the
finale, and the acclaim and awards speak for
themselves.
Look no further than the show's immaculate
second season as evidence as to why it still
holds the reputation it enjoys today.
It used to be far more outside the norm for
shows to kill major characters with little
to no warning.
The Sopranos made its bones in this trade,
and focuses its sophomore season on Tony Soprano's
best friend becoming an FBI informant.
The story spirals to an inevitable confrontation
between the two that plays out just as shockingly
today as it did when it first aired.
Even with all the stellar prestige TV shows
on the air today, we can't forget the original.
There's very little to say about The Wire
that hasn't already been said.
It's perhaps the single most acclaimed television
show of all time.
The Wire's tale of the complex lives of Baltimore
cops and criminals form a tremendously powerful
narrative about life, death, poverty, corruption,
and finding the light amidst it all.
While every batch of episodes has its strengths,
season four of The Wire is easily the best
the show has to offer - and when you're talking
about the best season of possibly the best
show of all time, you know it's something
special.
The show's fourth season sees the narrative
weave a story about the Baltimore school system
and follows the lives of four young boys who
have grown up in the area.
While there are other stories going on throughout
the season, the four boys become the season's
linchpin.
Season four is where the show stops asking
questions and starts giving answers, boldly
claiming that in a world ravaged by systemic
poverty, there is no level playing field for
those who grow up in it.
Their fate is predetermined and impossible
to escape.
As street dealer Bodie tells hard-nosed cop
McNulty:
"This game is rigged, man.
We're like the little bitches on the chessboard."
"Pawns."